[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles pour cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo c'est parti pour
30 minutes d'actualité européenne dans
cette émission direction l'espagne le
pays basque espagnol ce stade il y a
quelques années encore un fleuron de
l'acier européen aujourd'hui les usines
une à une ferme concurrencé par l'acier
chinois un acier à bas prix largement
subventionnée par pékin une offensive
qui met en exergue l'incapacité de
l'union européenne à défendre ses
industries alors faut-il un
protectionnisme en europe
on en débat tout à l'heure mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est le retour du ceta le
traité de libre échange de l'union
européenne avec le canada mais le
libre-échange vit-il ses dernières
heures ici en europe c'est la question
de la semaine
[Musique]
25 pour kas contre une abstention le
ceta accord de libre échange entre
l'union européenne et le canada a été
approuvé en commission
prochaine étape le vote en session
plénière prévue le 15 février prochain
la fin d'un feuilleton à rebondissements
pour cet accord controversé qui a
nécessité sept ans de discussions point
d'orgue octobre 2016 la petite wallonie
défie l'europe entière et le canada en
refusant de voter le texte en assemblée
régionale un paraphe indispensable à
l'aval de la belgique
paul magnette ministre président de la
wallonie devient l'égérie du camp anti
libre échange
le premier ministre canadien doit
décaler sa venue à bruxelles
après deux semaines d'atermoiements et
de négociations marathon le parlement
wallon philippaerts signé justin trudeau
est accueilli par ses homologues
européens en catimini un dimanche pour
signer le texte
mais le parcours d'obstacles n'est pas
pour autant terminée car le ceta est un
as corniste les 38 parlements nationaux
et régionaux de l'union européenne vont
devoir le voter à l'heure où les
discours protectionniste et anti
mondialisation ont le vent en poupe à
l'heure où donald trump et remettent en
cause le traité trans pacifique et
l'alena accord de libre échange nord
américain le cetas il entre enfin en
vigueur risque bien d'être le dernier
accord
né par l'europe
[Musique]
le ceta sera-t-il le dernier accord
signé par l'europe et quel avenir pour
le libre échange pour en débattre se
reçoit franck proust bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député européen membre du
groupe l'est républicain fin du groupe
parti populaire européen vous êtes
français vous êtes président de la
délégation française en face de vous
edouard martin bonjour jour vous êtes
vous mêmes députés mais membres du
groupe socialiste et démocrate bienvenue
enfin jean sébastien lefebvre bonjour
vous êtes journaliste correspondant à
bruxelles du journal contexte un site
spécialisé sur les politiques françaises
et européennes
première question à monsieur est ce que
le sénat a de bonnes chances d'être
votée en février
edouard martin écoutez moi j'espère que
non puisque vous l'aurez compris je
m'oppose à cet accord de libre échange
au cameroun la pause tout tout votre
délégation socialiste délégation
socialiste française après moult débats
on a pris position à gagner festival
gagné convaincre votre délégation
exactement au tenter de convaincre toute
la délégation socialiste du parler là il
faut qu'on ait le débat en groupe
effectivement on n'a pas la question n'a
pas été tranchée
mais s'il est voté encore une fois
j'espère que non ça sera une courte
majorité je pense vous êtes d'accord un
frank rost coûté j'aurais tendance à
dire que la proportion qu'a été
observées en commission un état devrait
être la proportion 25 15
voilà 25 ans devrait on devrait
retrouver cette même proportion
lors du vote le 15 février prochain
parlement européen parce que y compris
des parlementaires socialistes ont voté
donc avec un certain nombre de
parlementaires ppe
donc je pense que c'est un texte qui
devrait passer effectivement avec une
majorité c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
entend c'est à dire qu'il y aura la
droite du parlement européen qui va
voter pour le ppe en particulier mais
aussi le groupe sert les conservateurs
britanniques et polonais plus les
libéraux au centre et une partie des
socialistes donc on devrait tourner
autour de 400 entre 400 et 450 vote pour
le ceta sur 751 150 à une majorité assez
court donc le reste de la bataille
edouard martin si jamais il est adopté
donc mi février ce sera comme c'est un
accord mixte c'est ce qu'ont expliqué à
l'instant les 38 parlements nationaux
qui vont devoir eux aussi le ratifier ça
veut dire que c'est là que va se faire
la bataille
après effectivement chaque état membre
devra dire ce qu'il pense de cet accord
le ratifier ou pas rappelle comme qu'à
une pression énorme de la part la
société civile avec des vrais arguments
c'est pas uniquement pour dire non au
libre échange
le débat n'est pas là mais c'est à dire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les conditions de
cet accord dans un dans un contexte
politique un débat où effectivement on a
la volonté de mettre un terme à toutes
les dérives
est ce qu'il est bon par exemple nous en
france qui subissons la crise agricole
de voir des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de tonnes de viande de boeuf
arrivée sur le marché français pas bref
voilà donc chacun devra en toute
conscience prendre ses responsabilités
sachant quand même que n'oublions jamais
pourquoi nous sommes là et pour qui nous
sommes la somme là pour défendre
l'intérêt des citoyens
mais alors est-ce que c'est un bon ou un
mauvais accord parce que d'un côté on
nous dit que c'est un c'est un accord
qui régule en fait une libre échange qui
existe déjà et qui a le mérite de mettre
des règles claires et de l'autre on
entend effectivement que c'est ça va
mettre en péril beaucoup d'emplois en
l'occurrence dans le secteur agricole où
il ya il va y avoir ce risque de
déferlement entre guillemets de boeuf
canadien franck proust le déferlement
sur le boeuf en tout cas s'il doit y
avoir déferlement ses cinquante mille
tonnes c'est à dire 0 9% de la
production globale et ça sera pas avant
quatre cinq ans puisque aujourd'hui les
canadiens ne produisent exclusivement
que du boeuf aux hormones donc il faut
revoir leurs chaînes de l'inter d'elbeuf
d'arman du coup on a fait ce sont les
normes européens car ça pique donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas demain la veille
que le boeuf entrera au canada au en
france ou en europe
mais globalement j'allais dire c'est
toujours l'éternelle question quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui sens et à
quelle pourrait être la situation demain
avec le 7 1 est ce qu'aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens sont protégés est ce que nos
entreprises sont protégés est ce que nos
agriculteurs sont protégés je dis non
aujourd'hui on le voit très bien nos
indications géographiques protégées de
la part de nos agriculteurs sont
plagiées copier en toute impunité la
s'est pressée par le 7 a350 qui sont les
ige paix les plus exposés à la
duplication et qu'ils sont
susceptible d'être exportable est ce que
nos entreprises peuvent répondre aux
marchés publics non on l'a vu par
exemple quand alstom s'est vu refuser de
répondre à l'appel d'offres à montréal
alors que bombardier venez répondre au
marché d'île de france et d'ailleurs
depuis bombardier-alstom répondent sur
les appels d'offres en commun donc
aujourd'hui nous avons aucune protection
demain nous avons peut-être pas
forcément la protection j'aurais
souhaité par exemple sur la réciprocité
des marchés publics
j'aurais préféré une réciprocité totale
je passe de 10 à 30 voire 40
bon c'est non mais donc moi je parle du
prêt c'est un bon accord qui permet de
réguler et d'ouvrir encore la ligne de
conduite c est ce qu un accord améliore
ou en pire des choses pour moi est la
dernière les pose donc je vote pour le 7
ans edouard martin sur les aspects
économiques y aurait il y aurait
effectivement matière à débattre et voir
le pour et le contre
effectivement on peut dire qu'il ya des
avancées par rapport à l'existant mais
il ya quand même un point un point
d'achoppement majeur c'est les fameux
tribunaux d'arbitrage river le canada
est une grande démocratie l'europe est
une grande démocratie on a une loi une
justice complètement indépendante avec
des juges complètement compétent pour
quelles raisons pour quelles raisons les
multinationales ont fait une telle
pression pour obtenir ces tribunaux
d'arbitrage privé est ce que nos juges
ne sont pas assez compétents pour dire
le droit
c'est là où ça pose problème la crainte
et à juste titre sans faire de procès
d'intention mais c'est que effectivement
ces tribunaux d'arbitrage privé c'est un
peu comme les tribunaux commerciaux en
france ça reste celle entre soi et on se
fasse une loi a pas il ya un risque du
yar et démocratique selon lui un manque
de démocratie effectivement sébastien
l'afev pourquoi ça bloque autant sur
cette question du libre échange depuis
quelques années en europe
ça bloque ça c'est compliqué parce que
le
le or à dire tous ces accords ont été
lancés à une époque où finalement ce
n'étaient pas des sujets de société
l'accord sur le canada ait négocié
depuis 2010 6 gdi pas de signes ne
trompent pas et à cette époque là on en
parlait part entre temps il ya eu télé
ip et matt débat n'a vait pas le tti
paix non plus ils étaient équipés à
l'ancienne mais devra traiter mais avec
les états unis
exactement et donc depuis on s'est
emparé du sujet dans les opinions
publiques et ont des gens comme en 2014
les élections européennes ça a été mis
sur l'agenda politique par jean luc
mélenchon entre autres et les verts se
sent dans l'agenda politique et donc du
coup les gens s'interrogent sur qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans ces traités qui sont
très compliquées le cétacé plus de 1000
pages que pas grand monde a dû lire en
entier si ce n'est quelques experts à
droite à gauche et donc du coup il ya
une sorte d'incompréhension et en plus
aussi on voit que la mondialisation
heureuse qu'on a pu prôné dans les
années 2000 ne porte pas ses fruits qui
a des choses à revoir
que l'europe parfois apparaît un peu
comme un peu l'idiot dû village ça veut
dire que elles jouent le jeu mais enfin
sont restés voilà on a la chine ou les
etats-unis ou d'autres puissances qui
elles ne jouent pas le jeu et on a du
mal à réagir contre les abus des chinois
qui vont financer l'industrie de l'acier
pour le vendre moins cher et c'est donc
c'est en fait ces accords qui
cristallise le débat et parce que ça
devient quelque chose d'important aux
yeux des gens pour pour venir leur
emploi leur avenir etc
ouais donc c'est effectivement presque
une posture politique vis-à-vis d'un
d'une manière dont on perçoit le monde
est donc cette mondialisation mais grâce
à vous jean sébastien merci c'est une
transition toute trouvée parce qu'on
part à cesta au en espagne à quelques
kilomètres de bilbao depuis plusieurs
années l'acier basque va mal à l'instar
de l'acier européen en général c'est un
parfait exemple de la crise de l'acier
en fait en europe une baisse d'activité
et la concurrence de l'acier chinois a
obligé arcé lors que vous connaissez
bien
edouard martin a fermé l'usiné il y a un
an mais en septembre elles rouvrent avec
une baisse d'effectifs et des conditions
peu favorables aux salariés
reportage de cécile sexo
[Musique]
la sidérurgie ici c'est une affaire de
famille cros et luis et michael ont reçu
en héritage comme leurs grands parents
et leurs parents ils ont connu l'âge
d'or de l'acier basque quand ils ont
commencé à travailler en 1976 quinze
mille ouvriers prenez chaque jour le
chemin est aux fourneaux
lusine c'était le poumon de la vie
locale cette rue c'était fou il y avait
des milliers de personnes qui allaient
et venaient ne pas exagérer mais c'était
comme à l'entrée d'un match de foot
un petit match de foot de dix mille
personnes aujourd'hui les rues de sestao
se sont vidés
l'acier est en crise après la fermeture
des hauts fourneaux en 1996 remplacé par
une aciérie électrique
il ya eu la crise de 2008 et les plans
sociaux successifs à sestao désormais il
ne reste plus que 140 ouvriers procès
lui ce lui est parti il ya un an à 60
ans il a profité d'un plan social pour
prendre une retraite anticipée mais il
s'inquiète pour ceux qui restent
[Musique]
maintenant ici les enfants font ce
qu'ils trouvent surtout du service moi à
la maison j'ai ma fille qui est au
chômage on en fils qui a des missions de
temps en temps mais rien de fixe il n'y
en a qu'un qui a un travail fixe
les trois ont fait des études mais il
n'y a pas de travail
[Musique]
ruben 33 ans fait partie des rescapés
après avoir connu un plan social en 2011
il est rappelé en 2015 par arcelor qui
lui offre un contrat de quatre ans
désormais ils travaillent huit heures
sept jours d'affilée en horaires décalés
les conditions de travail ont beaucoup
changé entre le moment où j'ai commencé
aujourd'hui tout a changé
par exemple pour ceux qui comme
reviennent après cinq ans nous touchons
12 % de salaire en moins c'est dans
l'accord que nous avons signé un accord
médiocre on va dire pour tous les
nouveaux travailleurs
il leur faut attendre cinq ans pour
retrouver le même salaire beaucoup
d'entre nous sont en désaccord avec ça
mais bon sestao l'ancien fer de lance de
la sidérurgie basque tourne désormais au
ralenti
lusine est devenu symbole de la
décadence industriel de la région plus
assez compétitifs les sidérurgistes
basques doivent désormais composer avec
des prix de l'électricité très élevé
mais surtout avec un concurrent chinois
qui vend à perte et propose de l'acier
sur le marché mondial 28 % moins cher
que celui produit en europe et mouture
de la concurrence chinoise impact
beaucoup de secteurs de l'acier car
c'est un secteur sensible
c'est un secteur qui dépend beaucoup de
la demande et du coup ça se répercute
fortement sur les prix donc il suffit de
peu d'importations chinoises pour qu'il
y ait un gros impact sur les prix et sur
les bénéfices ici la chine et d'autres
pays comme l'inde ou la russie affecte
clairement la rentabilité de la
sidérurgie basque et européennes
moins rentables les industriels eux
basque revoient leur production à la
baisse et ferment des usines comme celle
de zumarraga les pouvoirs publics locaux
tentent de limiter la casse sociale
ils font pression sur l'europe pour
qu'elle prenne des mesures contre la
concurrence chinoise mais aussi auprès
du gouvernement espagnol pour baisser
les prix de l'électricité
en attendant le parlement basque propose
des solutions de reconversion aux
travailleurs le parlement régional
travaille actuellement pour trouver ces
alternatives et pousse le gouvernement
en lui disant écoutez travailler avec
d'autres institutions publiques pour
créer de nouveaux emplois nouveau tissu
d'entreprises pour trouver des solutions
pour ces gens qui même si nous relançons
le secteur de l'acier n'auront pas de
solution sur le vieux continent
en dix ans le secteur a perdu 20 % de
ses emplois
comme beaucoup de salariés européens
robben kroos et luis et michael sont les
victimes d'une guerre de l'acier qui
oppose la chine à l'europe
la commission n'a pas dit son dernier
mot elle vient de mettre en place des
mesures anti-dumping
[Musique]
des mesures anti-dumping ont été mises
en place donc et pourrait faire des
taxations qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 70
% environ pour la chine edouard martin
quand vous voyez cette situation à
cestas ça ne peut que vous rappeler ce
que vous avez connu à florange avec la
fermeture des hauts fourneaux
comment est ce que l'europe a pu en
arriver là laissé son acier enfin le
secteur de l'acier en crise à ce point
ce qu'on a péché par naïveté
on a évité par hypocrisie parce que on a
laissé à l'abandon tout un pan de notre
industrie parce que je l' ai vécu
pendant trente ans on nous disait là si
la serrure jc du passé faut passer aux
nouvelles technologies au numérique et
cetera donc haro sur l'industrie de base
et moi je fais partie de ceux qui disent
il n'ya pas de développement numérique
ou spécifiques sans une industrie de
base forte et le cas de sestao que je
connais parfaitement parce que je me
suis rendu dans le cadre de rapports que
j'ai effectué effectivement il ya une
conjonction de deux problèmes majeurs la
concurrence déloyale chinoise à côté il
ya le port de bilbao en 2015 il ya eu un
million de tonnes d'acier chinois qui a
qui a débarqué à bilbao
juste à côté et on puisse a été dit de
laura dans le reportage un prix de
l'électricité extrêmement cher et
l'espagne ne fait pas grand chose pour
l'espagne et comme le pays d'europe où
le coût du kilowatt est le plus élevé et
donc nous ce qu'on propose pour faire
face à haas et à ce défi c'est de donner
la possibilité aux industriels espagnols
par exemple mais aussi européens de
contracter des contrats long terme de
manière à ce qu'ils aient une visibilité
se stabilisant le prix de l'électricité
ritz était premièrement deuxièmement
effectivement nous sommes quelques-uns
monsieur proust en fait partie aa nous
battre avec la commission pour dire ça
ne peut plus durer
on ne peut pas accepter cette
concurrence déloyale il ya il faut
scission française sur ce dossier en
fait qui va au delà des clivages
partisans turf est intéressant tout à
fait et pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière la commission vient de d'acter
des droits de douane supérieur sur des
tubes inox qui varie entre 37 et 67%
vous voyez qu'il ya une prise de
conscience mais ça ne suffit pas à
passant de 7 % ça paraît un petit peu
ridicule quand les états unis font 266%
je crois
de taxation supplémentaire états unis
procèdent de la manière suivante eux ce
sont des droits de douane sanctions ça
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un accord à
clé avec les règles de l'om c'est
justement franck proust on voit bien
alors là il ya une position française
qui est de protéger notre industrie
c'est pas le cas partout on pense
notamment à l'angleterre une
l'angleterre enfin les britanniques ont
perdu l'équivalent de 5000 emplois dans
l'industrie de l'acier eux aussi touchés
par la crise et le déferlement de cet
acier chinois
comment réussir à faire avancer ce
dossier quand il ya une vraie fracture
au niveau européen sur ce
protectionnisme européen
oui je crois d'ailleurs que ça va au
delà des étiquettes et de l'appartenance
politique il ya une frontière qui est
une frontière géographique qui va du
nord-est au sud-ouest avec d'un côté
l'europe du nord qui est plus une europe
gelée dire orienté vers le monde de la
finance et puis une europe du sud qui a
encore quand même un passé et un vivier
industriels importants et j'allais dire
pour l'ade j'ai une émission bien connue
des paroles et des actes
on peut pas tenir à la fois ici au
parlement un discours en disant et à la
commission il faut réindustrialiser
l'europe et ne pas protéger cette
industrie donc il faut mettre en place
des mesures des instruments de défense
commerciale qui soit à la hauteur des
attaques que nous subissons et ce n'est
pas l'europe en tant que tel qui est
coupable
ce sont les états membres eh bien ce
sont des états comme l'angleterre la
suède la norvège l'allemagne viennent se
rallier à nous mais il y avait jusqu'à
présent très peu de pays il y avait la
france l'italie l'espagne l'allemagne
man en est avec nous dont il faut une
majorité qualifiée
effectivement la commission est venu et
on nous étions ensemble avec edouard
martin mais il faut aller plus loin
parce que au-delà des règles que nous
pouvons annoncer après c'est
l'application des règles et quand vous
mettez des règles je dis toujours il
faut des moyens humains des moyens
financiers c'est comme les accords de
libre échange
le tout c'est pas que des signes et cd
faire respecter c'est ça qui est
important
alors jean sébastien lefebvre ce qu'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
bien que la france sur cette position là
est clair il faut que nos industries
soit protégé ce qui est assez fou c'est
qu'on voit que plusieurs pays
effectivement ne se range pas à ce
constat est ce à dire que il ya beaucoup
de pays en europe qui ont abandonné
l'idée qu'on puisse avoir une industrie
en europe et qu'après tout à partir du
moment où on n'est pas compétitif ou
l'acier chinois des fermes
c'est pas grave à nous de nous lancer
dans le numérique et dans ce type
d'industrie du 21e siècle c'est pas
forcément qu'ils ont renoncé à voir une
industrie c'est plutôt ils se disent
moins l'acier pas très cher ça
m'avantage sacem
moi j'ai besoin d'un acier pas cher pour
construire des voitures monter des
pièces et c'est donc le fait que les
chinois décide de payer eux mêmes pour
faire baisser le prix de l'acier
finalement je sais pas une usine de
pièces détachées en plus de chèques se
dit battant bus roulent par exemple pour
nos machines à laver ravis que l'acier
soit pas cher exactement donc eux se
disent pour mon industrie chez moi je
vois pas le problème donc je vais pas
taxer cette assise plus sauf qu'il ya
une prise de conscience dans beaucoup de
pays qui commence à se dire bon si on
n'a plus du tout d'acier en europe on va
être complètement dépendant des chinois
et un jour ou l'autre
eh ben ils pourront dire finalement les
prix c'est plus ça et c'est plus si
avantageux et on va refaire remonter les
prix donc ça commence à bouger les pays
bas par exemple qui sont
traditionnellement très libre échangiste
ont récemment changé de position et
rejoint le camp français en disant on
peut pas accepter d'aller aussi loin
donc il faut il faut réagir donc c'est
pas uniquement ils sont contre
l'industrie c'est leur industrie leur
fait dire l'acier pas cher c'est bon
pour nous est ce à dire messieurs qu'il
faut qu'on aille plus loin quand on voit
que donald trump remet en cause le libre
échange remet en cause la lena remet en
cause le traité transpacifique que il
porte cette idée d'un protectionnisme
américain est ce qu'il faut pas qu'en
europe qu'on soit sur la même position
et qu'on mette en place une forme de
protectionnisme aussi en europe
edouard martin mais c'est pas c'est pas
du protectionnisme bea en disant je
ferme les frontières je ne veux que rien
ne peut naître c'est pas ça l'idée l'idc
c'est comme moi j'ai mon forme de
protectionnisme solidaire moi j'aime
beaucoup le football et vous voyez bien
qu'au football partout dans le monde on
a les mêmes règles pour tous c'est
exactement ce qu'on demande d'acier ses
170 millions de tonnes consommées chaque
année c'est quasiment 4 400 mille
emplois directs et je rappelle qu'un
emploi industriel engendre trois autres
n'ont pas beaucoup de l'acier parce que
effectivement nous sommes en pleine
crise actuellement mais je rappelle que
l'acier produit en chine et mes deux
fois plus de co2 que l'acier produit en
europe je rappelle combien on sort de la
côte 21 nous sommes en train de
légiférer aux fans nous allons légiférer
sur la réforme et est donc les échanges
de droits à polluer
comment comment voulez vous que l'europe
soit crédible si elle impose des mesures
drastiques contre son industrie en même
temps fermer les yeux sur ce qui vient
d'ailleurs qui ne respectent pas les
règles mais il ya l'acier il ya la
chimie il ya la céramique
il ya le vert il ya plusieurs il ya sept
grands secteurs industriels qui sont
aujourd'hui menacés de peut paraître en
europe
alors comment on les protège justement
franck proust mais en en ayant des
accords qu'ils soient d accord gagnant
gagnant et je partage les accords de
libre échange dont la problématique est
derrière derrière le mot libre échange
on a l'impression que c'est le
libéralisme sauvage celui qui détruit
nos emplois et nos industries
moi je suis pour le juste échange
j'agirai presqu'à à d'un dénommé cette
notion de juste échange sur un
protectionnisme intelligent a contrario
de ce que fait monsieur trump qui est un
protectionnisme inconscient lui c'est un
deal mais coeur quand ils commencent à
négocier il faut qu'il y ait un cadre un
gagnant et un perdant pour moi un accord
ça doit être un accord gagnant gagnant
qui protège nos concitoyens qui protège
nos entreprises et à nous responsables
politiques de créer un environnement
politique encore une fois qui va
permettre à nos entreprises qu'elles
soient grandes ou petites dalles et
pénétrer ces marchés d'extérieur parce
que encore une fois je le répète mais
j'insiste là dessus quand vous avez un
trou de croissance en europe qui va de 0
à 2%
si on veut relancer de la croissance si
on veut aller chercher de l'emploi il
faut aller prendre des parts de marché
l'extérieur mais conditions et je
rejoins cette ce parallèle avec le monde
du sport la mondialisation toute façon
qu'on soit pour ou contre
c'est un état de fait mais conduisant la
règle avec les mêmes règles
donc la notion de libre échange c'est
pas le j'aime pas ce terme parce qu'ils
engendrent quelque chose de négatif
un accord de libre échange un accord de
juste échange alors dernière question
jean sébastien est ce que le type dans
ce cadre là est mort à aujourd'hui on
peut dire que peut être été ip ne verra
pas le jour
on a une administration américaine qui a
clairement fait comprendre que l aller
par n'est négocié d'accord de
libre-échange comme on qu'on fait à la
commission européenne ils le disent la
commissaire au commerce extérieur l'a
sous-entendu en off aussi à la
commission d'entendre les gens dire
maintenant mais c'est foutu voilà donc
oui le tti paix ne verra pas le jour
et même après on peut se dire même si on
avait une administration obama qui avait
négocié jusqu'au bout est ce qu'en
europe il serait passé à travers les
parlements européens et nationaux ne
suis pas sûr qu'il y aurait une majorité
partout en europe pour faire valider le
tti paie donc là mais la méfiance est
pas la même c'est à dire que les
européens ne sont pas comme trump en
disant je reviens sur l'idée du libre
échange etc
mais sur la façon dont ces faits il ya
un vrai débat en europe et qui va encore
durer parce que ça allait être
effectivement débat va durer ya un autre
sujet qui fait débat ce sont les
travailleurs détachés
vous le savez bien et c'est l'heure de
notre checkpoints notre checkpoint
réalisé cette semaine par thomas mignon
qui a passé au crible une déclaration de
nicolas dupont aignan checkpoints et
tout le travail des tâches et volatiles
nos emplois en france nicolas dupont
aignan en a fait l'un de ses combats il
ya cinq cent mille travailleurs détachés
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
cinq cent mille emplois vaut lui ce sont
des voleurs d'emplois tout d'abord ce
chiffre est il courait le nombre de ses
travailleurs en mission temporaire était
de 280 milles en 2004
mais supposons qu'il évoquait aussi les
travailleurs non déclarés
la dernière estimation date de 2011 au
minimum deux cent vingt mille détachées
illégaux travailler en france
une petite addition plus tard le calcul
de nicolas dupont aignan n'est peut être
pas fils éloigné de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
mais ces potentiels 500 mille
travailleurs détachés représentent-ils
néanmoins autant d'emplois les 280 mille
travailleurs déclarés en france ont
effectué 10 millions de jours de travail
cela représente 46 mille emplois
équivalent temps plein et si l'on
revient à l'estimation de 500 mille
travailleurs
on peut calculer qui représenterait
environ 80000 e tp
mais quelle que soit l'heure d'onde ces
emplois on qu'il était volé comme le dit
nicolas dupont aignan en fait ces
européens occupent pour une bonne partie
des postes difficiles à pourvoir en
france comme par exemple dans le secteur
de la construction
et notons encore que les français eux
aussi sont des voleurs d'emplois à
l'étranger près de 200000 sont détachés
dans d'autres pays de l'union
alors yat-il cinq cent mille emplois
volées en france
non c'est faux c'est faux et c'était
donc le checkpoint de thomas lignon
messieurs merci beaucoup de vos lumières
sur ces sujets la question des
travailleurs détachés ce sera l'objet
certainement d'une prochaine émission
en attendant la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez ahmed tazir ici à bruxelles
sa belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]